la pf des yvelines et du val d'oise en
temps de promouvoir le droit à une vie
affective et sexuelle pour les personnes
en situation de handicap moteur mathieu
lopez pourquoi cette action aujourd'hui
une personne en situation de handicap
qu'on n'a pas le droit de vivre avec qui
elle veut et comme il veut et bien tout
d'abord elle peut rencontrer des
difficultés à se mettre en couple avec
un partenaire
on constate qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
préjugés qui existent sur le handicap
d'une manière très générale et encore
plus lorsqu'on aborde la thématique de
la vie affective et sexuelle des
personnes en situation de handicap
moteur il ya beaucoup de vision très
stéréotypes et de préjugés qui existent
à ce niveau et donc nous au sein de la
pf on s'est dit que c'était notre rôle
de faire bouger les lignes de
déconstruire ses visions et donc de
d'intégrer cette thématique de la vie
affective et sexuelle dans le débat
public de en faire un véritable sujet
qui sont abordables existants et non
tabou cette question effectivement
revient de temps en temps même on va le
dire assez assez souvent il est aussi
question des assistants sexuels par
exemple pour les personnes en situation
de handicap ça pourrait faire l'objet
d'une loi
en tout cas le souhait taxe au nom des
associations c'est sans doute ce qui
sera abordé le 5 janvier dans le val
d'oise à bouffémont dès 10 heures dans
le cadre du programme
oui donc que veulent développer with
comme en anglais avec le thème ses accès
à la sexualité dans la loi c'est la
première le premier des rendez vous
proposés dans le cadre du programme l'a
développée par la pf au tour de ceux de
ce droit voilà exactement donc servat
lieu au foyer louis xvi apf à bouffémont
dans le département du val d'oise
ce sera animée par catherine deschamps
qui en fait conseillère nationale
politique à l'association des paralysés
de france si linda war qui est lé
responsable du service juridique de la
pf et donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir
aborder le le droit des personnes en
situation de handicap au niveau de leur
sexualité de savoir également si
l'institution un foyer a le devoir ou
non de favoriser la vie affective et
sexuelle de ces personnes si oui de
quelle façon est également de mettre en
avant quelles peuvent être les droits et
aussi les interdits de chaque citoyen en
matière de sexualité
des fortes de la part des adhérents des
adhérentes sur ces questions là pour
avoir ce genre de réunions des débats
des groupes de parole aussi on évoquera
tout à l'heure mais ça fait partie des
choses que vous proposez oui il ya
vraiment une grosse demande et puis
c'est en plus des rencontres qui sont
animés par des par des spécialistes qui
peuvent être des juristes des
psychologues et gynécologues
voilà qui apporte vraiment leurs
compétences aussi au service du public
qui a la possibilité de pouvoir poser
des questions ce qui a inscrit
véritablement ses rencontres dans une
démarche participative interactive
donc il ya de vraies demandes c'est un
succès je pense donc au niveau 2 au
niveau du projet on compte renouveler
voilà pour 2013 mascella type de la
troisième étape du projet voilà
exactement été créé qu'en alors c'est un
projet qui a été lancé en 2011 par un
colloque sur la vie affective et
sexuelle à destination des
professionnels professionnels de santé
et qui voilà désormais s'adresse donc
aux personnes en situation de handicap
moteur et aussi à leur entourage
familial entourage proche également à
des professionnels de santé du secteur
social médico-social ainsi qu'au grand
public
parce qu'il ya vraiment une volonté
derrière ce projet risque de pouvoir
sensibiliser le grand public pour comme
on le disait tout à l'heure pouvoir en
faire un sujet abordable et notamment le
programme donc qui va se dérouler à
partir du 5 janvier avec le premier à
première réunion première discussion
autour des axes et de l'accès à la
sexualité dans la loi ce sera le 5
janvier c'est le premier rendez vous ça
va se poursuivre ensuite jusqu'en juin
et les temps forts le principal moment
ce sont ces groupes de paroles qui ont
été mis en place voilà qui vont débuter
à partir de la mi janvier jusqu'au mois
de juin en gros et une semaine sur deux
en alternance pour les hommes que pour
les femmes
voilà donc on a mis en place des groupes
de parole non mixtes séparés entre
hommes et femmes qui sont des lieux qui
permettent en fait aux participants de
pouvoir libérer la parole libérée leur
souffrance qui les lie à la difficulté
pour eux d'accéder à une vie affective
et sexuelle à de nombreuses privations
donc c'est un lieu que les participants
peuvent s'approprier c'est l'occasion
pour eux de pouvoir s'échanger aussi des
bons conseils
voilà des bons conseils des bonnes
adresses dans l'optique de pouvoir aussi
se créer un réseau et ses des lieux qui
sont donc séparés la réunion des groupes
homme a lieu dans le département des
yvelines à la maison de la solidarité la
solidarité associative de poissy et la
réunion des groupes femme a lieu donc
dans le département du val d'oise au
service d'accompagnement à la vie
sociale de cergy mais là justement
c'était pas un problème que ce soit
centralisé sur ces deux points là parce
que pour s'y rendre c'est pas forcément
toujours facile pour les personnes du
destin certains départements qui seront
dans l'autre département
l'objectif c'est d'être un peu plus
présent aux six ans voilà un rendez-vous
est exactement donc on a voulu quand
même mettre en place ce projet sur les
dettes par les deux départements parce
que voilà ça donne quand même du poids
et une visibilité à ce projet et puis
c'est un projet qui aussi régional et
pour nous cet échelon régional il
véritablement important parce qu'il nous
permet de mobiliser différents moyens et
d'apporter des réponses éparpillés à des
besoins qui on veut en fait c'est al
géographiquement sur l'ensemble de la
région
il y aura d'autres rendez vous également
que vous êtes en train de préparer
l'armée à citer les principaux
rendez-vous qui sont d'ores et déjà acté
qui sont écrit noir sur blanc sur un
programme mais pour la suite il ya
d'autres choses aussi que vous prévoyez
voilà donc on envisage également de
continuer à mettre en place des
rencontres thématiques
donc nous travaillons actuellement avec
le planning familial des yvelines et
aussi du val d'oise pour aborder
différents sujets notamment la sexualité
et ses risques donc entendus par cette
notion de risque en fait les mst les
interruptions volontaires de grossesse
également les comportements sexistes et
violent à destination des personnes
vulnérables la situation de fragilité et
on envisage de créer ces rencontres
thématiques sur ce thème à destination
donc des personnes en situation de
handicap moteur du grand public et aussi
d'en mettre deux mètres une rencontre
thématique en place à destination cette
fois des professionnels parce qu'il ya
une vraie demande aussi de la part
notamment des professionnels de santé
parce que les professionnels ne savent
pas comment aborder cette thématique
voilà ils rencontrent des difficultés
au quotidien dans leur pratique et
justement je pense que la pf peut aussi
être présent à ce niveau pour les
éclairer sur ses doutes et on renvoie
vers la pf pour avoir plus
d'informations sur le programme
également en savoir plus sur les
prochains rendez-vous qui sont en
préparation et qui seront bientôt
proposés merci donc d'être venu sur le
plateau
pour rappel le programme louise de la pf
des yvelines et du val d'oise pour le
droit à une vie sexuelle et affective
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap moteur
la chronique de l'écho à suivre pour
l'instant valérie auribeau qui est nous
emmène un maul dans un lycée privé
d'enseignement agricole avec parmi les
filières proposées une qui est unique en
ile de france elle concerne l'animalerie
j'ai la passion des animaux jusque
pendant les heures de pause au lycée
agricole le béa
les élèves du club nature créée il ya
deux ans prennent soin des tourterelles
rougequeue noir et pivert qui peuplent
le parc l'hiver ce lycée d'enseignement
privé est le seul possédant une filière
animalerie dans toute l'ile-de-france
sanctionnée par un diplôme reconnu
alors cette fille est on apprend les
bases des animaux de compagnie c'est à
dire on apprend à peu près l'équivalent
de 300 espèces animales rongeurs
aquariophilie oiseaux mais aussi
reptiles sont au programme car les nac
nouveaux animaux de compagnie sont de
plus en plus prisés
le python bull un serpent qui peut
atteindre un mètre cinquante et tue ses
proies par constriction le spécimen
n'effraie pas les élèves les goûts pour
les animaux ont largement évolué
dérangera concis m'attend c'est plus les
régimes ce que je sais pas c'est le
toucher et rousset nouveautés plan les
élèves qui viennent de partout en france
n'ont qu'une seule motivation se situe
derrière tout simplement par passion
donc voilà et toi de ce calibre
reptiles et poissons ici une centaine
d'élèves est réparti entre les classes
de seconde de première et de terminale
d'autres choisissent l'apprentissage ou
le bts technico-commercial 70 à 80 % des
élèves se destinent à la vente en
animalerie
d'autres se dirigent vers les métiers de
l'assistanat au vétérinaire ou encore
vers l'élevage l'animalerie reste l'un
des secteurs qui recrutent encore
aujourd'hui et si le respect des animaux
fait partie intégrante de l'enseignement
du lycée le respect de l'environnement
aussi le lycée agricole qui s'agrandit
actuellement a été distingué par un
écolabel